so really quickly we want to go back and
forth between these two kinds of things
what might be two to the power of five
okay so the first thing we'll do is we
will write it out in proper this is a
fizzer product isn't it okay so write
out with all the multiplication signs
this is two times two times two times
two
okay not adding we're multiplying okay
so let's see if we can do this two times
two is four times two again times 2
again times 2 again 32 there you go
that's 2 to the power of 5 okay how
about what would this be
let's do - negatives for you I should
say negative 3 to the power of 4 okay
now brackets be careful we're gonna I'm
gonna put them all the way through so if
there's powerful there I'm gonna
multiply it by itself 4 times so minus 3
times minus 3 times minus 3 times minus
3 okay so let's have a look that first
to write negative 3 times negative 3
that's 9 multiplied by negative 3 again
that'll be negative 27 do one more time
now 27 times that's a big number it's
going to be positive 81 can you see why
it's positive by the way ok these two
negatives speak back to our work with
integers right these two negatives
they'll cancel with each other and these
two negatives will also cancel ok so you
know yes say it again so these two
negatives canceled yeah so they become
positive these two negatives cancel so
you become positive and I've canceled
out all the negatives there were four of
them so you can see
if you'll that's a great question by the
way can I just say I'm so happy Rochelle
I sigh question because that is the
mathematical question right you look at
examples and the questioner bass is
always like well what patterns going on
here is it is this something we can
generalize now I can tell you in advance
right okay for instance if I were to put
a 40 there I don't know what maybe it's
pretty to the power 40 years but I can
tell you with confidence that it's going
to be something positive okay now the
question is how do I know I don't know
what the number is but how do I know
it's going to be positive okay yeah good
so let's have a think about that again
because that's really important right
have a look at what happened up here
right the way I was explaining it was
you look at these two and those two
negatives cancelling and then you look
at these two and those two negatives
cancel if you can pair up every negative
together they'll all live it at each
other right well 40 here right it's
gonna be some huge number but I know
that I can pair up all the negatives how
many pairs will there be there between
pairs right forty people you tell them
all to pair up and there will be 20
pairs right 3 times 2 again you could
say if I made it 401 even though we
don't know what the number is I can
learn that it's sign will be negative
why it's an odd number right so 400 of
the negatives they're all Paylor pair up
right
there'll be 200 pairs of negatives and
then there'll be that one right a guy
every like no one wants to hang with me
fine I'll make everything they do okay
so you can know in advance even if I
in fact I bet but even your calculators
don't know I think that's going to be
alright now
that was that was going from index form
to what we call an expanded form
obviously you could go the other way for
instance if I wrote this how would you
write that in the next form yes seven to
the power of three now you've probably
seen before or send before right when
you've got a power of three we have
another day fare we call it cubing right
so you'd read that as seven cubed okay
and it's the same with the power being
to if I said five times five you would
rewrite that as 5 to the power of two
but you'd say five squared wouldn't you
okay great so there you go now you know
how to trade change between forms you
know what it means I'm just gonna leave
a couple of questions
settling in your mind you can ask me out
later if you want I'm not gonna dress
them up front this is what it means when
you have a number like six or four or
five for a good one okay here are three
questions for you I don't get it so I
just want you to think about if somebody
you know I know the answers already just
think what might happen if what's going
for what if I had a power of zero what
would that mean to me I just want you to
think about it somebody might actually
read either what is what is the power
was it a whole number what if it was
something like a huff does that does
that mean something what if the power is
really worried about integers how do we
what if the power was negative what
would that mean right now it's
interesting because if I read this full
multiply by itself
zero times
this this is interested is it confusing
you can work out with a bit of thought
what all of these might equal to and
they're all numbers that you know okay
but the question is what do they equal
and why they haven't think about if
you're really choose you can ask me
later